no matter who you are no matter where
you are in life you can take the lid off
of your job there is nothing bigger than
your dream it's going to take more than
a notion to become successful like I
always say life is 10% what happens to
you is 90% what you do about it and you
got to play and play including extreme
yourself beyond your normal doubles come
and buy a first-class ticket
hello believe nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the world's major problems so to
help you on your journey today we're
going to learn some comedian TV host and
actor Steve Harvey and my take on his
top ten rules of success volume 2
rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the best and as always as you're
listening if something really resonates
with you there's a message that really
holds true to you please leave it down
the comments below and put it in quotes
so that other people can be inspired and
when you write it down it's much more
likely to stick with yourself as well
enjoy
no matter who you are no matter where
you are in life you can take the lid off
of your job and if you're wondering if
you still have the lid on in your life
here are some clues that's going to let
you know that the lid is still on if
you're not excited about waking up in
the morning if you're sitting around
bored out of your mind if you've got
time to do everything anybody asked you
to do you probably got the lid on if
when you tell your dreams to all your
friends it makes sense to them you got
your lid on man your dreams should be
should not make sense to everybody
you got to say something that make
people go how you going to do that
that's when you got to lead it off and
if I were you I'd do that I take the lid
off make sense we go to the one thing
that I have learned to relate to all of
my children is to dream there is nothing
bigger than your dream nothing is great
within your dream now as we sit in this
great educational institution I'm not
saying that your education is not
important because it's tied to a lot of
your dreams
but let me tell you something there
ain't nothing nothing bigger than your
dream because your dreams will prepare
you to get the education don't you ever
stop dreaming don't you ever stop
imagining we will talk about them two
things a lot but don't you ever stop
dreaming your wife say as a man without
a dream or vision Shall Perish that's in
your body you'll exist in the one out no
way in that does it say without
education you package and it says
without a dream or vision you pass me
so if what you're dreaming about
requires an education it is being your
dream that prepares you to get the
education but the dream is bigger than
anything man Thievery was an education
that calls you to be greater successful
I am here today because I don't have one
of them but nobody could out dreaming
your dream is everything there it's the
biggest part of your life look man it is
that thing that God would send you they
don't let you sleep sometimes it's your
dream it's that thing that boys and that
wakes you up and stares the very fit of
your soul I've always taught my children
to dream but secret though the secret to
real success is if you tie your gift to
the dream it's going to take more than a
notion to become successful
because once you get this degree it's
actually just going to be a piece of
paper on the wall it's really hard this
can be
some people may give you a job with it
most enjoy to people and tell you how
much experience you need so you got a
hustle man kind of hustle hustle and
grind dig man kind of fight go for that
a lot of dog in your man to be rich and
if you just want a job
get yourself a little child a nice
little life get a little house so
Frankie yourself a little minivan the
station wearing go ride your life but
ain't nothing wrong with that but if you
really really really want to be bald I
changed some people's lives get yourself
some real money
hire people get more than one stream of
income company got be a hustler man
I'd be a hustler you all in a techie and
[ __ ] is money my buddy came by you
having his dance don't have no money he
say you would go be polisi hide every
lead in a car for three years
discoveries but I had a dream and a
vision and I got there also that house
every man in this room you met you blew
your twenties you spend all your 30s
trying to make up for the old toy you
know that's that after truth job every
dude in this room blue day 20s and 8:30
trying to fix what they should it be a
10-8 20s yeah and so so for the song you
turn 40 you're trying to recover from
the mistakes you made when you're 30 now
have fought it many times you start
really at 30 you need to start buckling
it on down and just realize man
everybody make mistakes and if the
mistakes you going through I'll go help
you become the person you need to be
later on see father all the mistakes
don't they cool to make you I needed to
mess up every marriage I needed to get
arrested like I did yeah I needed to get
shot I needed all this dog you got I
needed I'll be home yeah because all the
people have you torn up man you get shot
it it don't hurt it just burn that's a
complete I'm telling you shot ain't what
you want I needed all them things to
happen to turn me into Who I am today so
when you're young and you make mistakes
don't let them eat you up because
everybody that delayed it tomato yeah
you got to fail in order to win Hey look
man to understand how to hit the game
where they shot you got to miss the game
when it shots Steve Harvey yes yeah well
I'm stuck in a rut because I can't seem
to follow through with anything I went
to college for a year and a half and I
dropped out then I went to cosmetology
school I completed that but I never went
back to get my license then I was a
pharmacy technician and I recently left
license expire as well I just feel like
so many people that are my age and
they're already set in their careers and
I just feel like at 29 I'm a people
person so I want to do something like
Human Resources and I just need help
like where do I begin
first of all you're talking about stuff
that I can relate to like so many others
can relate to I mean you know everybody
got the same story we just got different
details like I always say life is 10%
what happens to you is 90% what you do
about it so we're going to dive into a
chapter from my new book and it's
chapter 1 section 1 this is very clear
for people so the first step is getting
completely and brutally honest enough to
say I am tired of myself when you say
I'm sick and tired of being sick and
tired
that's the facilitator of change that's
when you're ready to say these words no
more excuses no more excuses I went to
Kent State I dropped out I applied and
drop out of flunked out now that threw
my life into a spiral but because I
didn't have a college degree I could not
let that stop me and like you're doing
were you saying all my friends at this
age are settling in your career you
don't even know if they happy or not
stop comparing yourself to others so the
first thing you do is stop focusing on
other people instead focus on being the
best version of you that you can then
you recognize that you deserve to sit at
the big table with everybody else after
you become the best that you can do now
once you've accepted that you have as
much right to success and much right to
succeed as anybody else
the next step is learning how to talk
the talk you have to get fluent in the
language of success so you speak it with
ease surround yourself with people
who've accomplished their dreams and
immerse yourself in the culture of
achievement I've learned
if your farmer farmer understands better
than any other worker in this country a
farmer has an understanding and most
people never achieve in their line
I really respect the farmers and their
commitment but I respect also they
understand my grandfather my uncle the
thing was to wake up early in the
morning before you start your day you
start your day by feeding all the
animals I never understood that
why must being sloppy hauled bailing his
hay for these cows taking food out to
the hunting dog I'm going to get these
meals and horses walking them down to
water
why am i feeding these chickens mess all
this before I my grandfather senator
dynasty young man if we don't take care
of these animals that we are requiring
to take care of us he said what's going
to happen oh he said we dependent on
them chickens to maintain to give us
meat we dependent on him home for me we
dependent on the news to pull the plow
so we complain we dependent on them
horses to drag all these wagons were we
dependent on these hunting dogs to go
out in wood and uncover animals for he
said aunt
what I respect about farmers is they
understand that everything comes in
season there is a planting season and
you got to plant and play and plant and
Clinton plow he'll hold a role you've
got to do all that seeded fertilizer and
on the for co-op to grow now here's what
happened some years some years is the
drought ain't no way ain't no clouds
sometimes it's a flood wipe out all on
the clock all the plants but guess what
you still got to do the plant because
what you're banking on it's just enough
way just enough sunshine
so you can harvest and even if they
crops get washed out even if the floods
come even have to drop clothes
one thing about a farmer they do it all
over again because they understand that
eventually you'll be able to harvest and
that's what I respect about farmers and
that's my life you know you got to be
tough because the road to success is
always under construction it's never a
clear path to success the people who
become successful other people who have
our relentless attitude and you just got
to hang in that through the bad breaks
because the band breaks is coming but
they usually come right before the big
break is about to happen
you get a series of bad breaks and it
stumbles up a lot of people my life and
my success is to say to anyone you can
stumble you can fall you can get back up
again and like I said before we each
have a gift but too many people miss out
because they refuse to sign the lease on
their gift you keep looking for it
outside of you stop sit with yourself
what is it that you do to absolute best
with the least amount of effort that's
your gift but if you are
after looking outside of yourself and
you don't latch on to your gift you will
never find your purpose if you want to
succeed you must commit to your own gift
and embrace it
knowledge is necessary to get you to the
next level but after you get to the next
level that's what all that sounds of
what
geometry history all that's out the
window man
sorry you know you got it you gotta
learn this and this can only be learned
in life man what y'all sittin here
catching man firsthand is life lessons
that you can use when you will be 58 you
understand you ain't over
I mean you just can't get this is not
available you got to see it so what
you're actually doing is si think about
knowledge man
you can Google knowledge you could go
online and get knowledge or anything you
can you can press a button and read
about this and read about that it you
can go and repeat that and people are
wow these knowledge okay cool but
exposed exposures totally different
exposure is when you see it touching
feeling gold an experience
that's different exposure
once you open your mind to exposure you
can never shrink your mind back down
cause exposure don't decrease once
you've been exposed and your mind
expands from exposure
you can't shrink it back down and act
like this okay see you once you fly in
first class
you can't walk past them without feeling
some kind of weight and watch you people
shut that curtain you can't cause the
whole time you back there see when I
flew coach man everywhere live because
that's what I could afford it to when
the plane take off or they close that
curtain the whole time I was wondering
what are they doing on the silent cut
well they're denying you the exposure
because they can't show you they can't
show you watching them people get a
whole can
they can't show you that eighty-eight
nuts warmed up in a container they can't
show you that they give all them people
are hot scented cow to freshen a face
and handsome they can't show that to you
because you didn't pay for so you bought
- coach teacher so they closed it
curtain don't even let you come again
used a bath because they just need to
keep these ten seats available for those
people that painting that's what your
curtain is closed because they know what
to expose you to then you don't want
okay our home care to cook we can't do
that you don't pay I'm also hot fingers
no no no now on the airplanes you got to
take not at your figure you got to pay
for the sandwich you're gonna pay for
the meal now you get a choice but you
got to buy it now it straighten your
first-class ticket gets you a frequent
kiss you more than one well unless you
can get free drinks of your own paper
beer and drinks in first claim it comes
with the cost of the ticket so once you
sit in first class and you open your
mind expose your mind to it
see bro you can go city and coach them
because you get exposed but if you keep
walking past first class and let them
close the curtain and never get the
experience you you can grow your whole
life thinking coach's arm but mess
around and buy yourself a first-class
ticket you will forever be changed and
you'll never forget what first-class was
like but that's the beauty of exposure
it makes you pain and and and perform
towards the exposure now so that's why I
did Greg Lee said you should always
whenever you can go first class extend
yourself beyond your normal levels of
comfort and buy your first class ticket
get you a first-class
get you a first-class parachute because
once you put it on you understand what
they charge and not go forever change
because through exposure your mind can
naturally back down knowledge you can
forget when Christopher discovered
America you
get you can forget that equation for
gravel you can forget MC squared
you can forget that you can forget
what's the cause of the Piru figure you
could get the square root of 181 you can
forget the square root of 81 that's
novice come on that has that mister back
yet as the back yeah man that looks
pretty good yeah they look pretty good
I'm like there you're like that's a
pretty good look I got that I got this
too in case this is but this is the next
step if you don't do the green juice
that's the you end up with that if you
look to the green juice and then going
along yeah that sounds like a very we're
back
we're back with chief Harvey everybody
talked about his new book feel great
here we go talk about a damn tie my shoe
is off the wheel hey hold people Harvey
calm down sir what can I can I get you
anything we gave you a good juicer
anything I want no damn juice I want a
ham sandwich and arrogance oh my girls
thank you guys so much for watching I
really hope you enjoyed this video if
there's someone you like me to profile
in the next top ten check out the link
in the description and go and cast your
vote I'd also love to know what was your
favorite message from this video what
did you learn from this video that
you're going to immediately apply
somehow in your life or in your business
please leave it down the comments below
I'm really curious to find out I also
want to give a quick shout-out to Cyrus
Webb Cyrus thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book your one word and
posting it to LinkedIn with your review
I really really appreciate the support
man and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the
book so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
about simple millions you know to be
honest with you I'm very fortunate in
that I love what I do so we're hoping
that if you I'm on every day I'm gonna
talk show every day I got a lot of radio
show pull out every day I love what I do
and I'm gonna Schumer to keep me alive
in your house today but I act like I'm
eight you don't know if you go now
floppy little old again my life is
really 10% what happens to you and 90%
what you do about it
look everybody in this room everybody
watch it everybody got something they
got to deal with get to dealing with it
stop complaining about it
complaining about it only makes it stay
present do something about it so life is
10% what happens to you is 90% what you
do about don't you know that however
your life is that it can be even more
wonderful than it really is
and young people do you to know that
whatever you right that's what you gonna
be I was showing somebody by telephones
my iPhone I got two iPhones you cut them
on you cut my iPad on you come a laptop
of you cut every desktop I got in every
office I got the same vision board
pop-up opens I know you had a vision
board
you got one if over got visible lying on
Hanah vision but what I'm praising I've
been I've been studying successful
people for a long time they all do the
same thing they all got visions and
dreams and goals they all written down
somewhere they all wake up excited about
they life they all run out of hours in
the day because they just can't get it
all done and they can't wait for
tomorrow
there's your life ain't like that is
cause you already living your life in
the full
right now who problem is that